[Music]
[Applause]
We Make Way for Jason mccordi NFL
Network good morning football analyst
and uh was on the call for the uh Chiefs
and the Ravens Westwood One radio he
joins us on the program what bothered
you the most about what you saw with the
Ravens against the Chiefs the offense uh
the defense figured out in the second
half they were shutting down the Kansas
City Chiefs for the most part for some
punts but Lamar Jackson and the offense
they never were able to get anything
going you look at the way the game ended
the two running backs Gus Edwards
Justice Hill they both had three carries
a piece uh they threw the ball a ton and
when they did throw it Lamar when he got
the ball there wasn't any quick
processing every play seemed so hard
even the remarkable plays he made where
he spun off and he threw one to Z
flowers those plays seemed so hard Steve
Spagnola made it so tough for that
offense to get anything going that was
very disappointing this year was
supposed to be different from an
offensive standpoint with mon in the way
Lamar was playing throwing the ball for
the pocket and we just didn't see any of
that on Sunday okay as a former
defensive back explain to me how Travis
Kelce still gets
open he's so good against zone so good
and then he shows you a manto man with
the first touchdown pass with Kyle
Hamilton on him who has been tremendous
this year as a DB All Pro and all of
that perfect ball placement back
shoulder catch he makes it for the end
zone
but as you watch Travis Kelce even
studying for the game getting up to it
Buffalo played a ton of Z and he knows
the exact spots he's such a smart
football player and got a chance to talk
to him a little bit before the game the
first thing he said to my brother was
we're coming for every record that the
Patriots have and it's starting today
and he did it he was unbelievable 11
targets 11 catches it's insane they
didn't double team him much they just
let they just try to go play their
defense and you just can't do that when
Mahomes is the quarterback and Kelsey's
the guy he's throwing to yeah that's
that's the guy I got to worry about I
mean I I like Pacho I mean rice I they
do have some players that's the one guy
I got to stop like that's where it begin
I'm not going to stop momes but I got to
stop Kelsey that'll help me stopping
momes exactly you go into that game and
it's just like first drive of the game
they're hitting Kelsey a fourth and one
they're rolling out they're throwing
back it's like you go into the game all
right if we lose this game at the end of
the day it's not going to be because
Travis Kelce killed us and he's not
getting a record on us and he did all of
the above what bothered you the most
about the Lions and the ners the
collapse I mean you're up that many
points you get to the second half and
yes a lot of attention should be paid to
Dan Campbell going for it on fourth down
beyond that the drops the fumble it just
seemed like they went in at halftime and
we saw CJ Gardner Johnson he's waving to
the crowd scores 217 got a little over
their skis feeling really good moment
seemed like it got too big and they
collapsed in that second half and I do
think for Dan Campbell I get it the
aggressiveness the fourth down play
calls that's what got them in that game
that's the way they've approached every
game going forward but it's like now
you're here you're in this moment and
you go up 17 points if he kicks the
first field goal but Josh Reynolds drops
the pass he could have extended the
drive but then later on in the game a
chance to tie it up I thought for sure
right there he would take the points but
disappointing to see the Lions how far
they've come this year and just kind of
fall apart in that second half but this
what I don't understand this you know we
watch basketball and I always say don't
let the best player on the floor beat me
I'm I'm never I don't want Michael
Jordan to have the ball I don't want
Kobe to have the ball whatever it takes
they're not beating me because now I'm
going to have somebody who's not used to
taking those shots why are you going to
Reynolds and
not Aman Ross St brown or leapa like I
that's what I don't understand and
granted leapa is a rookie but still he
had an unbelievable year I want those
players who have been in the position
their go-to guys to at least get the
ball or trying no doubt about it and
it's almost the same thing Jordan at one
point he kicks it to Steve currry he
makes a big shot John Paxton those guys
step up and make a big shot Josh
Reynolds has been a guy you look at the
game against the Rams he was a guy that
stepped up and made some big catches and
I do think you designed plays to go to
whether it's Amar whether it's Sam
leapor who leapor had one of his hands Z
man ra did too so it was almost like a
team wide thing on offense where they
kind of fell apart but Josh Reynolds is
a veteran you need him in those moments
to step up it especially the first one
it was a play where golf is scrambling
around he's looking for anybody and it
would have been a first down so I'm with
you you design those plays to go to your
guys but sometimes they take it away and
you need somebody else to step up and it
was Reynold's moment to do so and he
didn't we're talking to Jason mccordi uh
NFL Network good morning football
analyst was on the call uh with the
Chiefs and the Ravens on Westwood one
going forward who's more likely to be
back in the title game the Ravens or the
Lions oh I'm gonna say the Ravens and I
think uh if they can figure some things
out they have a lot of free agents
that's going to be the tough thing for
them a guy like Justin mataba had a
career year he may go get paid somewhere
but I still do think Lamar Jackson is a
great great football player he's
probably gonna be a two-time MVP the
difference is they can get back to that
game but it has to be more to figure out
to get over the hump I think for Lamar
Jackson as you watched that game there
was a big difference when you watch
Patrick Mahomes those quick easy passes
they come with a blitz he knows exactly
where to go with the ball he's not
holding on to it with Lamar on the other
side there was a lot of holding on to
the ball lets him make great plays but
too many times a game kills him what's
it like when you're facing a running
back like Isaiah Pacho like he runs hard
I it feels like he runs harder than any
running back is he running
harder yeah he definitely is as a former
DB that's one of those things where
during the course of the week I tell the
linebackers and the D linean do whatever
the hell you got to do don't let this
guy get to me untouched in the secondary
because that's not that's not what I'm
paid to do I'm paid to cover these guys
on the outside not to have these head-on
collisions with PCO but he definitely he
runs angry he runs pissed off and I love
it because he's a former Scarlet Knight
Ruckers guy Ruckers Legend and he sets
the tone for those guys because not only
does he run hard but watch him he gets
up after a hard run he's yelling he's
screaming I'm watching him at the end of
the game as they're taking a knee and he
is just walking around the field
screaming looking at his sideline
looking at Baltimore's sideline so I
think everybody feeds off of his energy
when do you make your Super Bowl pick oh
that'll probably be coming next week um
it's going to be a tough one I'm not
doing too well Championship weekend I
had the Lions and Ravens in the Super
Bowl so I've heard a lot from the Chiefs
fans in 49ers so far of I have egg on my
face and I just need to shut up at this
point so my predictions are struggling a
little bit right now how's Peter shreer
doing on his pics oh shr's walking
around there's no hat that's gonna fit
his head right now uh because it's like
five years in a row he's picked the
right winner and then of course this
year he picks the exact matchup so he
tries to act like it's not a big deal
but his head's bigger than ever right
now is this a dangerous Super Bowl
town this is a dangerous town no matter
what why do you think they they say
Vegas you only need about two days and
now Super Bowl people are going to be
out there for an entire week so um you
got to get in get out have a great time
but it's gonna be fantastic I can't wait
to be down there but did you guys ever
sneak out when you were
playing I never I never snuck out and
made it all the way uh there to Vegas
but the no no I'm talking about when you
were like the night before a game did
you
guys there so never in Vegas I played
there in 21 and no one stuck out people
are tired coming from Miami but there
was a year I was playing for the Titans
and we went down to Miami and we had 16
guys late for curfew and of course we
lost that game the next day a few guys
stayed Sunday night after the game and
had to make it back Monday before our
first meeting none of them uh made it
back Chris Johnson was on that team I
saw him tell the story somewhere of the
whole recap he was one of the guys that
stayed but that was that was history in
Tennessee that everybody talks about
that game in that night where we had
that many guys late for kiry it's called
the Miami flu there
jaay no doubt about it yeah uh hey
thanks for joining us great to talk to
you again anytime appreciate you having
me that's Jason mordi NFL Network good
morning football analyst he and his
brother uh on the call he's done a great
job NFL Network I that's a very
comfortable watch and listen with that
group uh